♪ (music) ♪
Well, thank you everybody for being here.
Today we're going to be giving a talk
about the new TensorFlow debugger,
which comes included with TensorBoard,
and it's basically a debugger
like you would see in an IDE,
that lets you step in,
set breakpoints and models,
and watch tensors.
But before we do that,
I'd like to give you some background
on TensorBoard,
and some of the other developments
that happened in the last year,
which we unfortunately
don't have too much time to go into,
but TensorBoard is basically
a web application--
it's a suite of web applications--
that was authored by about 20 people,
and it's all packed into a two megabyte
command-line web server
that works offline.
And TensorBoard can be used
for many purposes,
with all the different plugins
that have been baked into it.
The one you're all
probably most familiar with,
for those of you
who have used TensorBoard,
is the Scalars Dashboard.
You can plot anything you want.
It could be loss curves, accuracy, etc.
And these things sort of
help us understand
whether or not our model is converging
on optimal solutions.
And here is a really interesting,
underutilized feature,
called the embedding projector.
And this was originally written by Google,
so we could do things like
project our data into 3D space,
see how things cluster,
like if you're doing MNIST,
the sevens go over here,
and the nines go there.
And we actually recently...
What you see on this screen is,
we got a really cool contribution
from Francois Luus at IBM Research,
and he sent us some pull requests
on our GitHub repository,
since we develop in the open,
and what he did was, he basically added
interactive label editing,
so you can sort of go in there
and change things,
algorithms like t-SNE,
give your data-- sort of reveal
the structure of your data,
to learn more, search Google for:
"Interactive Supervision
with TensorBoard."
This is another really amazing
contribution that we received
from a university student
named Chris Anderson.
It's called the Beholder plugin.
And this basically gives you
a real-time visual glimpse
into TensorFlow data structures.
Like, for example,
as your training script is running,
it's real time-- and it does
require a hard drive, by the way.
It doesn't work with something like GCS
at this point in time.
I think this could be
a very useful tool going forward,
in terms of model explainability.
Now, TensorBoard also has some
new plugins for optimization.
Cloud recently contributed
a TPU profiling plugin.
And TPU hardware is a little different
from what many of you might be used to,
And TensorBoard with this plugin
can really help you
get the most out of your hardware,
and ensure that it's being
properly utilized.
Now, the TensorBoard ecosystem...
Part of the goal of this talk,
before we get into the demo,
is I want to attract more folks
in the community
to get involved
with TensorBoard development.
We use many of the tools
you're familiar with,
such as Typescript and Polymer.
We also use some tools
you might not be familiar with,
like Bazel, but we use it
for very good reasons.
You can also explore our readmes,
if you go to that folder for all
the different plugins we wrote originally.
Now, with TensorBoard,
the reason why this is just a little bit
more challenging
compared to some of
the other web applications
you may have used in the past,
or written in the past,
is we deal with
very challenging requirements,
like, this thing needs to work offline;
it needs to be able to build regardless
of corporate or national firewalls
that may block certain URLs
when it's downloading things.
For example, one of the first things I did
when I joined the TensorBoard team,
wasn't actually
visualizing machine learning,
but rather adding a contribution to Bazel
which helps downloads be
carrier-grade internationally.
And there there are a
whole variety of challenges,
like when it comes to an application like this,
but those burdens are things
we've mostly solved for you,
and here is a concrete example:
Writing that toilsome thousand-line file
was what it took
to make TensorBoard look beautiful offline
anywhere in the world,
without having to ping fonts.google.com,
and that's just one of the many burdens
that the TensorBoard team carries
on behalf of plugin authors.
Now, I want to give you
a quick introduction
for Xin Zhang who is the author
of this TensorFlow debugger,
and with the help of Chi Zeng.
So, as I mentioned earlier,
TensorBoard has always done
a good job
being the flashlight
that gives us broad overviews
of what's happening
inside these black boxes of models.
What the TensorFlow debugger plugin does
is it turns that flashlight into an X-ray.
Using this plugin, you can literally watch
the tensors as they flow in real time,
while having complete control
over the entire process.
This X-ray is what's going to make it
possible for you to pinpoint problems
we've previously found
difficult to identify,
perhaps down to the tiniest NaN,
at the precise moments when they happen.
That's why we call it an X-ray.
It reveals the graph of math
beneath the abstractions we love,
such as Keras or Estimator,
or as was recently announced today, Swift.
Whichever tools you're using,
this can potentially be a very helpful
troubleshooting tool.
So, I'd like to introduce its author,
Xin Zhang, who can show you a demo.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
Okay, so, in a moment
the screencast will start.
Great. Thank You, Justine,
for the generous intro.
So I'm Xin Zhang,
and I'm very glad and honored to present
the featured plugin for TensorBoard,
among many awesome, amazing plugins
that people have created
for TensorBoard so far.
So, the debugger plugin, for some of you
who may know TensorFlow debugger
or tfdbg,
it's the graphical user interface
of tfdbg,
and tfdbg has had only a command line
interface until recently.
So, like the command line interface,
the debugger plugin will allow you
to look into
internals of a run intensive flow model,
but in a much more intuitive, interactive,
and richer environment in a browser.
So, in this example, in this talk
I'm going to show you two examples.
One example of how to use the tool
to understand and probe and visualize
a working model that doesn't have any bugs in it;
I'm also going to show you
how to use the tool to debug a model
with a bug in it,
so you can see how to use the tool
to get to the root cause of the problems
and fix them.
So, first let's take
a look at the first example.
And that's the example being shown
on the right part of the screen right now.
So it's a very simple TensorFlow program
that does some regression,
using some generated synthetic data,
and if we run a program in the console,
we can see its works.
We can see a constant decrease
in the loss value during training.
Now, even though the model works,
we have no knowledge
of how the model works.
And that's mainly
because in graph mode,
Session.run is a black box
that wraps all the computation
in one single line of Python code.
Now, what if we want to look
into the model?
What if we want to look at the matrix
multiplication results in a dense layer?
And what if we want to look
at the gradient
on the matmul operation, and so forth?
The TensorFlow debugger,
or TensorBoard debugger plugin,
is a tool that can allow you to do that.
So, to start the tool, we start the usual
TensorBoard binary,
with a special flag, debugger port.
So, in this case we specify
the port to be 7,000.
Now, once the binary is running,
we can navigate to our TensorBoard URL
in the browser.
Now, at the startup, the plugin tells you
that it's waiting for connections
from TensorFlow Session.run,
and that's because we haven't
started the program yet.
It also provides you code snippets
that you can use,
whether you are using tf.Session,
Estimators or Keras models,
and in this example
we're using tf.Session,
so we're going to copy and paste
two lines of code into our program.
The first line is an import line,
and the second line is a line that
wraps your original tf.Session objects
with a special wrapper
that has the information
of where to connect the port number.
Now, with our programming
instrumented,
we can start the program again.
Now, as soon as the program starts,
we can see the graphical user interface
in the browser, switched to a mode
that shows you the graph
of the sessions are run in two ways:
In a tree view on the left,
and in a graph on the right.
In the bottom left corner,
you can also see what
Session.run is currently executing.
The tree structure on the right
corresponds to namescopes in your model.
For example, the dense namescope
corresponds to the dense layer.
One thing you can do,
is to open a source code on view
to look at the correspondence
between your graph nodes,
and which lines of the Python program
created those nodes.
If you click matmul, for example,
you can see the corresponding node
in the graph view.
You can also see which line
of the Python source code
is responsible for creating that node.
In this case, it's where we call
dense layer, as expected.
If you click another,
if you click the last answer,
you will see the corresponding node
in the graph again,
and you can also see where it's created
in the Python source code,
and it's where we call
the mean squared error.
And the gradients namescope corresponds to
the backpropagation parts of the model,
so that's how the model's trained.
You can click around, poke around,
and explore how a TensorFlow model
does optimization and backpropagation,
if you are interested.
And these nodes are all created
when we call
gradient descent optimizer.
You can continue to any node of a graph
and pause there.
So, we have just continued
to the matmul node in the dense layer.
You can also continue to the gradient
on the matmul node, which we just did.
And in the bottom right
corner of the screen,
you're looking at succinct summaries
of the tensor values we have continued to,
you can look at their datatype,
their shape,
and also the range of their values.
So, in the health pills, you can look
at how many of those values
are zero, or negative, or positive,
and so forth.
If you hover your mouse cursor
over those health pills,
you can get more information,
such as the mean
and the standard deviation
of the values in the tensor.
So, next we can click these links
to open a detailed view of those tensors.
So, in these detailed views you can apply
NumPy style slicing
to reduce the dimensionality,
so it's easier to look at the values
of high dimensional tensors.
We have just reduced the dimension
from two to one.
So we're looking at the value as a curve.
Now, next we're going to
continue to the last tensor,
which is a scalar,
and the shape is an empty list
as we can see here.
We can switch to the full history mode;
we can look at how the value changes
as the model is being trained.
So with the focus trim mode enabled,
we're going to continue over a
number of Session.runs,
like, 50 of them,
so we can see in real-time
how the last value decreases,
and how the values on the matmul
and its gradient changes.
So that's how you can use the tool as an
X-ray, or X-ray animator for your models,
to have a better understanding of
how your model works.
So, next let's take a look at an example
of a broken model.
So that's the debug MNIST model
that was shipped with TensorFlow.
That's the only broken model
we ship with TensorFlow,
as far as I know, and I'm proud to be
the author of it.
And if we run the model, we can see
the model doesn't quite work.
After two iterations of training,
the accuracy gets stuck at about 10%.
Now we suspect that there might be
some bad numerical values,
like NaN - Not a Number,
or infinities in the model,
but we're not sure which nodes
of the graph are responsible
for generating those NaNs and infinities.
So to answer that question,
we can use the debugger plugin tool.
We start the banner again,
and do a Refresh in our browser,
and then we can start our debug
MNIST example with a special flag
to connect to the debugger plugin.
So again we're looking at the graph.
Now in order to find the nodes responsible
for the infinities or NaNs,
we can check the checkpoints to
activate watch points for all the tensors,
and we can use the
conditional breakpoint feature
to continue the running the model
until any tensor contains
infinities or NaNs.
So right now you're seeing a list
of tensor values.
Those are a complete list of tensors
involved in training the model.
So, in a moment,
the model is going to stop,
and that's because it has hit an infinity
in the tensor call cross_entropy/Log().
Now, we can see in the health pill--
we can also see in the
detailed tensor view--
those orange lines,
and those show you the infinity values.
Now the question is, why do those
infinity values happen?
So, we can go back to the source code,
and find the line of Python code
where it's created,
and that's where we call tf.Log.
We can also open up the graph view,
and we see the input,
so we can trace the inputs.
In this case the input is the Softmax tensor.
So we can click expand and highlight
to look at the value of the inputs to Log,
which is Softmax, and now we know
that there are indeed five values
of the tensor which are zero,
and the reason for the infinity
is because we're taking log of zero.
Now, with that knowledge we can go
back to our source code and fix it,
although we're not going
to do this in this demo here.
Alright so that's
theTensorBoard debugging plugin,
and I encourage you to use it,
explore it,
and hopefully it will help you understand
your model better,
and help you fix bugs much more quickly.
You can just use this simple command line
on TensorBoard with a special flag.
And with that, I would like
to hand this back to Justine.
(applause)
Well, thank you Xin Zhang,
I thought that was
a really interesting demo,
and it was a great leap forward
for TensorBoard,
and it really shows that one of the things
we've been doing recently,
is rather than being a simple
read-only reporting tool,
we're trying to explore
more interactive directions,
as we've shown you today.
And this is something that folks who
are productionizing TensorBoard,
such as Cubeflow,
should take into consideration.
We also want to attract more contributors.
We have two approaches for this,
where you can develop
in our official repo,
and send us pull requests.
We do our work in the open.
This does need approval
on security footprint, etc.
And there is an escape hatch,
if that doesn't work out.
You can independently develop plugins,
you can create custom static builds,
without anyone's approval you can do
whatever you want,
because part of the goal on this team
is to liberate the tools.
With that said, I just want to thank
all of you for attending,
and I want to thank those of you
watching on YouTube,
if you like this talk,
please hashtag Twitter,
or, you know, reach out.
Thank you again.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪